-It's Adam Sandler.
It's great to see you.
-I'm happy to see everybody.
Everybody looks very nice.
You look fantastic.
-Oh, come on, buddy.
You look great, too. It's great
you're here in person.
-Yes.
-You helped us out
during the Zoom shows.
-Of course. That was great.
-I appreciate that.
-Oh, by the way,
when we just shook hands.
Did we ever --
Isn't it, like, a dilemma
if you're supposed to shake
or fist bump?
You ever see three people
you know...
and you hug two and then you go,
"What am I doing?"
And then the third person,
you give a fist bump,
and then that person
is kind of like,
"Why didn't I get the hug?"
And then you go,
"Oh, 'cause I don't like you."
-I noticed there's something
going on in your eye, buddy.
-I had an accident, everybody.
Everything's alright,
but I wish it was a good story.
It's pathetic.
So, what happened was, Jimmy,
I'm in my bed.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God. Wow.
-So I -- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm in my bed.
It's 4:00 in the morning.
And somebody made the bed.
You know when they make the bed
and they tuck in
the bottom part of the bed?
So -- So I'm in the bed
and I'm kind of like --
It's 4:00 in the morning.
I forgot to untuck it.
I'm going, "Why is it
so uncomfortable here?"
And I'm feeling squished
and I have --
My phone is here next to me
in the bed.
I always, before I go to sleep,
check out my net worth
on the phone, you know?
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
As one -- As one does.
Yeah, of course.
-You got to know
how life is and all that.
So, anyways, I, for real,
started getting panicky,
and I kicked my legs.
It's like, "Goddamn bed."
And voom --
And the phone flies in the air
and hits me in the face.
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Laughter ]
That's so funny.
Anyways,
I was bleeding terribly.
I mean, I thought --
It was pitch black in the room,
and I feel --
and I feel wetness.
And I go, "Yes, I'm --"
I tricked myself.
I go, "Those are probably
just thick tears."
'Cause I really was so tired.
-You cry sometimes
when you sleep?
-Yeah. I was having a sad dream.
No. I didn't want to get up,
you know, because I was tired.
And I was like,
"Ah, we'll fix that later."
So I slept,
and then I think I took a pillow
and put it on it
to stop the bleeding.
And then when I woke up,
it was horrible.
It was bleeding all over.
It was gushing still and --
-Blood all over the bed.
-There was blood on the bed
and all that stuff.
And then --
So I went to the -- I said,
"I got to get this fixed,"
so I went to the Apple Store.
-Yeah, you got to get --
Yeah, make sure that worked
and yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
How is the fam?
I know you have
two beautiful daughters.
-As do you.
I saw the pictures of the kids.
They look incredible.
-Thank you, buddy. Yeah.
-Gorgeous. Yes.
-How old are your kids now?
-13 and 16.
So they had a bat mitzvah and
a sweet 16 on the same weekend.
That was a big deal, right?
Bat mitzvah...
[ Applause ]
-That's a lot of party.
-It was a big party.
It was such a giant party we
threw for them, me and my wife,
that I literally had to sign
a new 10-picture deal
with Netflix to pay for it.
I was like -- I need help, man.
-But I heard that this is
the one that I heard
Charlie Puth -- Halsey was at
and performed? Come on.
-Yes. They were awesome.
They were great.
-That's a good dad.
-Such nice people.
-Good mom.
-Yes, yes.
Actually, they --
The kids had the greatest time.
And Halsey and Charlie Puth
were great to them all
and included them.
And the kids sang with them.
And they -- it was beautiful.
But it kind of warped their
heads a little bit thinking,
like, that's what happens
at bat mitzvahs.
And, like, they went to a bat
mitzvah a couple weeks later,
one of my daughter's friends.
I said,
"How was the bat mitzvah?"
One of my daughter's friends
said, "Oh, it was lame.
You know,
they didn't have no --
The kid's grandmother
sang karaoke."
I was like, "That's -- You know,
that's actually nice."
You know? And it was actually
Barbra Streisand, too.
-Oh, wow! Hey.
Yeah. They don't know.
-They didn't know.
[ Laughter ]
-You sent over --
You sent over a photo...
-Yes.
-...which I think
this is very sweet.
-This is incredible.
-Tell us about this.
This is your --
-That's my wife's grandma.
106 years old yesterday.
And she's awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's amazing.
♪♪
-She's a beautiful,
funny, nice lady.
Always in a good mood.
And just a good, good lady.
And I love her.
And the whole family loves her.
-What's she doing here
in this picture?
-She's pointing -- You see that
she's pointing in that shot?
She's pointing at me saying,
"you'll never live this long."
[ Laughter ]
No, no.
So, I do love her very much.
We all went to see her
in Florida
and then bought her a cake
and put 106 candles
on the cake for her.
And just to make it fun, I --
The candles were the
Gwyneth Paltrow vagina candles.
So, you know, the "smell
like the vagina" candles?
-Uh-huh.
-So we put them on the cake.
-Hang on.
There's more. There's more.
And, so,
Grandma blows very hard.
-Okay.
-And a lot of smoke in the room.
-Yeah.
-You know? 'Cause she just
put a lot of pizazz
into the blow to get
all 106 vagina candles out.
And then everyone in the room
was pregnant.
-There you go.
That's a great party.
Unbelievable.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I want to talk about
your fantastic movie "Hustle."
Congrats, bud. I loved it.
-Thank you.
-This movie is --
It's set in the world
of professional basketball.
-Yes.
-I know you love basketball.
-And LeBron James calls you up
and says,
"Adam, we should do this.
I want to produce this movie
with you."
-His company, LeBron's company,
and Joe Roth,
they had this great script.
And it was about a scout
discovering someone overseas,
bringing him into the NBA,
and it was awesome.
And I got to know LeBron
a little bit and I asked him --
I do play a lot of hoops,
so I wanted to get a quick tip.
And I said, "Anything
you suggest to fix my game?"
And he goes, "You should
definitely -- It's very simple.
You should definitely get
a full body transplant."
And so I said,
"Yeah, I'm going to do that."
-That's interesting. Yeah.
But that right there,
I would want to see the movie.
LeBron James, Adam Sandler.
I'm in. I will watch this movie.
I'm so psyched.
-Thank you, man. It's cool.
-And then you get to see
Queen Latifah in the movie.
-Your queen.
-That's my --
I love Queen Latifah.
-What a nice, great lady.
-She's unbelievable.
-Beautiful. Funny. It's funny.
She can do so much.
She can sing, rap,
act, drama, comedy.
And everyone just loves her.
And I said,
"She can do all that."
And you start getting jealous
when you're around that nice.
She can do that,
but can she look like
she hasn't slept in 30 days?
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, you really -- Yeah.
You got to have something.
You got to leave something
for yourself there.
You know what
I was going to ask?
Because I know you got some
skills. I've seen some --
You go to different pickup games
every now and then.
-So you --
Somebody told me you hooped.
When was that?
-This is -- I was in college.
This is my most famous
story ever.
I retired from playing.
-What happened? Tell me.
-I'm in Albany, New York.
I was in college.
Saint Rose. Walked down.
There was a pickup game at --
I can't say the name
of the park.
S-Talkers Park.
-Okay. Okay. I got you.
-S-Talkers Park.
I go there, and I'm just
playing a pickup game
with my friend Danny Martinez.
And we're going...
And there's maybe 30 kids around
the court watching the game,
rooting for everybody,
and one of the hoops is bent.
So you can --
The rim's a little --
You could dunk it
if there's no one there.
And I practiced and did it --
I could dunk the basketball.
-That's sick.
-Yeah. It was pretty cool.
But I would never do it
in a real game.
-Right, right, right.
-So I'm playing the game.
There's people in --
I'm terrible.
And I'm just bad.
I'm sweating and everything.
And I'm just --
I have weird moves and stuff.
I have a move where I can --
I can foul you with this hand
and then air-hook it.
And it never goes in,
but it looked cool, you know?
So I'm doing this thing
and I steal the ball
and I get a fast break.
-Uh-huh.
-And it just, like, starts
going in slow motion,
and I'm like...
And my fat is jiggling around
and sweat coming off. I go --
And everyone's going like,
"There's no way this dude
is gonna dunk this ball."
But it's the rim
that's pulled down.
It's very possible.
And I go...
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like, "Don't travel.
Don't travel."
One, two. Ga-doosh!
I dunk the ball. People go nuts.
They lift me up. I'm like Rudy.
They take me home. You know?
And I retired
from playing basketball.
-That's unbelievable.
-Yeah.
My friend Ralphie Salazar
is my --
He knows that it happened.
-He saw that.
-He saw it. He really knows
it happened for real.
-That's amazing.
-It's the best thing
that ever happened to me.
I retired. I couldn't --
I couldn't believe it.
I couldn't ever go back.
-Can you believe you got up
that high,
even if the rim was bent?
-You know, I thought maybe
I should go back in a disguise
and just, like,
look back at the court.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
And feel that moment again.
-Yeah, yeah. Like "Eddie
an the Cruisers," you know?
-Yeah, man.
-"Oh, he's a legend.
He doesn't exist."
-Oh, man. Yeah.
-But did you ever have a story
like that?
Did you ever dunk it?
-Dude, I literally --
I've never in my whole life
came close to the rim.
Everybody talks about
touching the rim,
and I can't even
get the backboard.
I can't even like -- When
I hit the bottom of the net,
I'm kind of like,
"I got the net."
I know. It's pathetic.
I don't know why.
I just can't jump.
I'm so slow, too.
I remember when I was
in Little League baseball,
I thought I was so fast.
Because I tried so hard.
I hit a ball.
I'm running to first as fa--
You know, like, I never knew
how to pump my arms.
I was like, "Do you do your
hands like this or like this?"
And I was just like --
And I remember seeing my dugout.
All the kids just
laughing and laughing.
I was like, "Oh, they're
laughing in excitement
of how fast
I'm going right now."
I came back, I was like,
"What happened?"
They were like,
"What the hell?!
How do you run that slow?!"
I was like..."I run slow?"
-"I was going normal."
-There was no video cameras
back there
showing you how goofy you were.
I literally thought
I was incredible at everything.
-Well, I have a video
that someone shot of you
doing something spectacular.
Take a look at Adam Sandler
making a balcony shot.
-Oh, okay. Yes, yes.
-Look at this thing.
-My name is Adam Sandler,
and you are watching
Balcony Ball.
-Ohh!
♪♪
-...carry you. I want to carry
you around like Rudy!
I want to carry you around
like Rudy!
That's what I'm talking about.
-You can't lift me.
-Yeah, I can. I want
to talk more about "Hustle"
and show a clip
when we come back.
More with Adam Sandler,
everybody.
That's how you do it.